thank you so much for having me here you
know sunny here gives me so many
memories you know just walking through
Huang remembering my teaching assistant
classes and and I brought back my
memories of when I was a grad student
here at Stanford now Stanford's not just
special to me because I'm not I'm an
alumni here but also because we started
one concern right here four years ago it
was here where I met Tim and aha with my
co-founders where we eventually became
friends and he became friends because we
shared common values if you gone through
our demographics for the co-founders we
are very different my age I'm an Asian
woman
hermits Muslim Indian and Tim's
Caucasian from the military but you know
we had fun at Stanford always talking
about large problems and just really
getting to know each other
now one fine summer of 2014
Mohammed went back home to Kashmir and
if I'm not sure if he know about this
but Kashmir India had one of the largest
floods that here a flood which they
hadn't seen in several decades we tried
very frantically to reach out to him we
would see the news talking about how
many hundreds of people ended up losing
their lives and we couldn't reach out we
couldn't connect with him and was very
very scary ultimately we did end up
connecting with him to figure out that
his family and him were safe after the
flood however when he came back to
Stanford he talked about so many stories
related to the Kashmir flood and it was
pretty modifying it was a disaster in
all sense K there was complete chaos
after the disaster you would have no
sense for the emergency rescue to figure
out where they should actually go who
should they actually rescue he had
thousands of people abandoned on the
rooftops with me for several days and
you have hundreds of people either
drowning or being washed away by the
flood and we wondered why is this still
a problem and and wise in the 21st
century why is nobody thinking about it
what can we do to help just being
graduate students here a little while
later because the opportunity to work in
a class project together it was the
machine learning project at Stanford as
well as the probabilistic earthquake
engineering class at Stanford and we we
took that opportunity to figure out can
we actually solve that problem we saw in
the summer of 2014 and and what can we
do to reduce that chaos the goal there
was just you know let's find a way to
figure out what exactly the problem was
and the problem we try to resolve was
can we provide a real-time granular
understanding of which buildings and
which people are in what state of
collapse during a disaster
so that was a problem statement our
backgrounds of computer science
structural engineering and earthquake
engineering led to it being focused
mostly on seismic initially and and we
were very happy with the results it was
surprising cause it wasn't done before
but there's a lot of physics and science
already there in structural and
earthquake engineering all we did was
sort of understand the features present
there and really convert that in a more
granular and real-time solution we're
happy with the algorithm we created but
what we were more pleasantly surprised
was that when we presented this
algorithm in the in the in the CS 229
machine learning fair a lot of
professors came up to us a lot of
investors came up to us and said that
what you have is applicable and you can
create a real product here now we were
taking a little aback because we never
thought of starting a company or of
creating a product and none of us had
experience running a business before
two-thirds of us were immigrants myself
an argument and I'm not sure whether
it's similar thought process but when
you're immigrant generally you come to
Stanford you know your thought process
is work hard study hard get good grades
and then fines are a putable place to go
to so that you can then give
back to your family who sacrificed so
much to just make sure that you come
here so so when somebody came up to us
and said you know you should not think
about the idea this way think about what
our product could look like it was a
little hard for us because that meant
that there is obviously going to be risk
associated with creating a company and
we didn't have any background associated
with that so what we insert there is we
try to see whether what we're hearing
from our professors and from from the
investors is that really real so so we
cold called a bunch of different cities
a bunch of different emergency officials
and we ask them that hey you know we are
three clad graduate students here we
have this algorithm we really don't know
whether or not it would be helpful or
not can you spend a few hours with you
to just understand is this really a
problem and can we can we do some impact
here and we're surprised that instead of
them spending a few hours they ended up
spending several days with us the hope
and the excitement we saw in these city
officials I think that was the final
push to make us say that you know we
have to do this it sort of came to light
that it is a responsibility we and if we
don't do it will anybody else think
about this problem or will this problem
keep repeating itself so then all the
three of us the three co-founders we had
a really hard conversation at least
actually several hard conversations
about what we would have to give up in
terms of our previous ideas and what
does it mean to commit to to a mission
and what does it mean to commit to a
company now while I talked a little bit
about you know my aunt Ahamed as
immigrants you know are our problems
tim himself was raising her family so
you know what would that mean in terms
of his responsibilities but at the end
of those conversations we said you know
we are all in you know we have to do
this and once once we figure out that
the
is the problem you want to solve we then
started thinking about the next step the
next step is you know parallely
continuing our conversations on what the
product would look like with the cities
but also figuring out that we cannot
build a very complex machine learning
pipeline for disasters with just the
three of us so building a team building
something actually feasible so that
meant trying to figure out do we want to
actually do this on our own raise money
ourselves or start looking at investors
it was hard for us to pitch in money
ourselves you know being immigrants and
all and so that meant that we did have
to go through the investor out now now
that was a little surprising as well
because when we went to investors we
thought you know obviously these cities
are so excited you know we heard about
product market fit you know customers
didn't like it so you know investors
should definitely jump on this idea and
you helped us through but that wasn't
what we saw for around nine months we
mostly heard rejections and it's very
hard to hear that because along with the
risk you're taking you hear somebody
really experienced with a lot of
expertise and building a business coming
to you and say saying no you have a
noble idea but it's just an idea and you
need to give it up I have an anecdote of
a particular investor which we were
really you know we really respected and
that was one of the meetings which I
still remember we went into the meeting
we gave our pitch tag and and the
investor said you know if an earthquake
happens I'm just gonna walk out and go
to my neighbor's house this is such a
silly idea and you should start thinking
about something else completely and you
wasted so much time so nine months of
not or just hearing rejections nine
months of not knowing basically
collecting debt and then nine months of
real big fear from your visa process you
know what's going to happen can i still
stay here do i have to go back to india
it was pretty scary for
but instead of having that bring us down
what we did was we took a step back we
said you know what are we not doing
right we did we didn't blame the
investors or the feedback we realized
that there's something missing in what
we are doing which is why we couldn't
portray our story to to the investors
while talking to us and so we later
realize that the problem was twofold one
problem was we weren't talking to the
right set of investors you know they are
different investors with different
investment thesis so they're few in the
seed stage who definitely want to look
at evidence in the market you know put a
strong ratio or weight on that as part
of investment in your company
and given that there was no earthquake
gov tech product out there you know just
really high risk whereas there are other
investors who put a lot of weight on the
team is there need you know and that the
team's gonna figure it out like really
large focus there so we realized that we
need to start looking at you know these
investors the second thing we realized
was what was missing in our pitch was we
always thought about the vision but very
little about the feasibility of the
business and we knowing that we didn't
know that too much we took whatever help
we could get we went to Stanford
adventure studio are talking to all the
Stanford graduate students they're
pitching several hundreds of times and
and just brainstorming about what could
be wrong we talked to investors for
advice even the people who rejected us
telling them of what could we have done
better what is actually the problem and
we we invited all that information in
and an hour ago eventually finding the
right investor and helping them
understand exactly the perspective of
why this idea should be present was what
founded one concern so fast forward
today we crew from the team of three to
a team of eighty and our mission is for
a world of Raziel
where we see resilience in the three
pillars of safety equity and
sustainability and we obviously expanded
from seismic to floods and fires and to
talk about what the issue in seismic is
when an earthquake happens right now
what what what is in the hands of
emergency responders there's two things
you might get one is a map where in
entire neighborhoods or cities a color
are colored a single color you know red
yellow green telling them that that is
the impact for a city the second thing
is you probably seen it on Google it's a
shake map you see really large red
concentric circles on the map and that's
sort of what a responder is supposed to
take in and and do those life-saving
decisions so when you think about why
the chaos follows after it's obvious you
know just looking at a blurry map how
can a first responder know what to do
and when when several thousands of
people need help so we moved from that
idea into the idea on the left really
focusing on going really granular on a
block by block level and even building
level helping people understand which
which buildings are on what sort of
collapse minutes after the earthquake
happens we not just do building level
information we understand understood
that the people component is very
important so who resides in those
buildings are they low-income are the
senior population are the children
because the resources you spent you send
during a disaster are very different
based on the vulnerable population who
are affected Hurricane Katrina is an
example where in most of the there were
a lot of senior citizens who had
abandoned and they needed an influx of
blankets because they were shivering
during the hurricane but no one knew
exactly what was the ratio of people who
are affected so that's the second
component we focus on in in a product
and finally the third component is we
don't want to just predict which
buildings are down all we want to help
cities understand
is which what is the state of the city
so that implies not just looking at
direct causes of impact but also looking
at secondary and tertiary causes of
impact so is is a power sector down is
your healthcare down is your water
system down and how does that ultimately
go and affect citizens give an example
you might have the strongest Hospital in
the world which might be up during the
big one and during a big earthquake but
if the Hetch Hetchy system is down or if
the power system is down and there's no
sort of back-up plan it still means that
your health care is affected it still
means that citizens aren't getting that
rescue so how do you protray a cascading
effect of dependencies along with the
impact map to the first responders flood
we just released last November and we
chose floods specifically because it has
a larger impact and it is definitely the
impetus of one concern the Kashmir flood
it's more or less similar to what we do
in seismic the only difference is that
you could actually forecast five days
into the future
now when hurricane Harvey happen or any
hurricane happens what data these cities
understand is a storm is coming it's
going to come in three days
it gonna get five inches of rainfall but
how does that help you know who to
evacuate and how does hazard help you
know who is going to end up drowning in
that particular incident so it's a pride
providing that really granular impact
and of good and updating your accuracy
as and when you get real-time input from
on the ground we are very transparent
about how accurate or inaccurate our
models are in fact that's what cities
love they want to know how can they help
us make our models even more accurate we
want them to be able to make those
decisions after understanding where our
models wouldn't work and where our
models will work in the final third
component which is still in development
is fires fires are very close to
California the costliest is
sort of last year was the wildfire in
California now the issue of impact
knowledge and situational awareness is
even la is probably larger or or equal
to that of floods and fires floods and
earthquakes you have fires moving at 80
miles per hour literally engulfing
football fields in seconds and meanwhile
the only data which is coming in is 911
calls or the recognitions where you're
driving around the neighborhood how does
that help you really understand what the
state of impact is and how does that
have first responders or firefighters
really evacuate ahead of time and and so
that's sort of our different offerings
and we moved to not just doing response
we understood that it's not just about
during the response helping save a few
lives it's definitely about how do we
prevent the loss in the first place we
work with cities like San Francisco Los
Angeles and mult and get also in the
midst of deployment internationally
we're in we're in what we do is have
them do more efficient planning how do
you prevent this loss in the first place
one is just through looking at multiple
different scenarios seeing is your
emergency response system actually
capable of responding to it
do I need to increase my budgets do I
need to add more resources do I need to
communicate better so that's what we
call a scenario planning but the second
thing is about reducing the loss in the
first place
so that's through by the city planning
that's through better infrastructure
adjustments just trying to figure out
even addition of you know that Hetch
Hetchy water pipe which would have you
know cause a lot of chaos to the high
health care in California so how do you
like really prioritize among all those
decisions and we're doing this not just
for governments we understanding and
helping people work together in our
resilience ecosystem wherein we get in
different commercial sectors and
governments talking the exact same
picture during a large event most of the
small medium businesses will absolutely
go bankrupt so how do you have people
understand that this is the state of
what our disaster risk is and how do I
prepare for it ahead of time so what
what we do here is you know we call this
benevolent intelligence where and we
really want to use artificial
intelligence for social good and we
really think that we can enable a
disaster-free future and what I mean by
this Astor free I mean that hazards will
keep happening you'll have seismic
events you have floods you'll have fires
but cities and citizens will be able to
immediately bounce back and that
bouncing back would happen because of
immediate response during a disaster
through better planning before a
disaster and even through you know
better infrastructure updates and it's
it wasn't so that's that's one concern
and they were we we come here like I
said we've grown pretty large but it
wasn't very easy coming to where we are
they they've definitely a lot of
challenges we had to face and so the two
different challenges I'd like to focus
on is number one is surround yourself
with the right people
it's always going to be about the people
you have the right people
I think 75% is already half done and
what do I mean by people I mean by
obviously the the team the people you
hire you know we've been lucky
we've hired not just divorce thought
processes but like divorce in terms of
age gender race etc but also in terms of
thought trusses we have firefighters we
have emergency managers we have mayor's
we have data scientists we have a
collection of a lot of different thought
processes which enable us to understand
how can we fix this through policy and
technology and make sure definitely that
the bar you'd keep for your mission
alignment is as high or maybe even
higher than
technical bar or the business body
looking for don't compromise on that
we've learned that the hard way that we
should never do that I give you a quick
anecdote of an interview we did in the
early stages of one concern we had this
really really smart engineer come to
interview with us I'm really impressed
by what he could do
so I interviewed him and one of my other
engineers interviewed him and he was
very rude and condescending throughout
the interview didn't let me complete my
sentences and I I was taken aback and
after we did a debrief the the CEO came
in saw Hamed and he was like no that guy
was wonderful he was very nice with me
he was very respectful so I don't know
what was the difference after looking
through a debrief notes it was pretty
obvious that the person who came in had
a bias towards being respectful to you
know men in particular and you know that
was a complete whether or not he was the
most smartest engineer in the world
I couldn't have somebody come in and be
disrespectful to my team and this was
not just something I thought of AHA met
the entire team agreed that this was
something you would always stand by so
culture shouldn't be something light you
should be willing to not hire if
somebody is not your culture and really
stand stand by it the second people
component especially for a
mission-driven company is definitely
surrounding investors so during the seep
town it was a little bit hard but
ultimately we ended up in a series a we
got a lot of interest for multiple
different investors now say we we caught
somebody on the board who told us that
you know this is a way you could get
more dollars but you'd have to give up
your mission of saving lives in any
sense you know that's a complete no-go
for us as well and so we wanted to make
sure that there is complete mission
alignment with our investors and we took
a lot of time with the potential
investors asking them where do you see
one concern for
what would you do if if you are not
seeing all attraction in this particular
markets really just understanding how
they would react to this and are they
really aligned to our larger mission of
saving lives and so we were pretty lucky
getting the right board members on board
and I do think that is something you
should always insist on getting to know
your board members and understanding
that we are all all in sync on what our
mission is
the third one which is obvious is of is
is your founders the cofounders you work
with so I was lucky I mean if I was
friends with my previous co-founders we
sing Donna values but you know you need
to be I've been so vulnerable with my
co-founder several times I've broken
down completely I've told them all the
different flaws have had and they've
done the exact same thing for me when
things were rough I could call either a
her mother Tim at 12 o'clock in the
night and freak out and let them know
you know this is the problem and they
would not take hold it against me they
would let me take a step back and they
would give me their perspective of what
I could do pattern and I would always do
the same for them which comes to my
second challenge the emotional burden of
you know running a company being a
founder is going to be very lonely it's
going to be very hard because you always
want to be the pillar of strength for
your employees for your founders for
your clients for even sometimes for
everybody you know you always want to be
the pillar of strength who people to
people go to but there's going to be a
lot of ups and downs many downs more
than ups generally in the start and if
you are not careful it can take a really
large toll on you you need to be able to
take a step back and and do what I did
similarly in the rejection piece which
was don't take these rejections
too hard critically on yourself take
this as opportunities to really learn
from it
how can you take that negativity or two
and convert it into something you can
learn from and it's very important to
find the right support system as well I
have have a very
my family's completely bought in
initially they want and then my friends
are completely bought in you know they
know that I might not be able to spend
six months with them because I'm working
so hard on one concern but they all
support me through and through
so it's very important to find the right
support system otherwise it will be very
very hard on you if this and despite I
guess but a one last component I want to
talk about is don't look too much into
the details when we started a company
the technology was very very scrappy we
just build a bare-bones web application
you know actually a machine learning
algorithms were on MATLAB or MATLAB
server and we didn't really care about
let's find the most latest technology
and let's make it the coolest app ever
what we'd instead focus on was let's
work with the cities and really figure
out what exactly should this be and now
obviously that's not the case we have a
very very secure a lot of micro services
and we did invest in technology but
don't overthink that focus on what
really matters which is the problem even
something you want to work on and you
know despite all the different
challenges I talked about I would always
do this again
the excitement I see with the team I've
surrounded with the opportunity I have
to just work with phenomenal people to
make a difference you know always will
make makes it worthwhile and and you
know if I didn't do this I I don't even
know would this problems will be solved
would anybody think about it I'm hopeful
that at some point you know five years
from now we're able to create at least a
single metric on on a wall in the
company which talks about the number of
lives we affected in a positive manner
and that would be completely worth it
and so if there is a particular idea you
have or and you really believe that it
has to exist you should go for it do
some research obviously the research we
did with the different cities but but
take that step and don't and and it as
long as you are completely committed and
you
the right team with you you know it
should solve itself out so I think
that's pretty much it
[Applause]